and jury deliberations continue this
morning in the trial of a former
Minneapolis police officer who shot and
killed an unarmed yoga teacher Mohammed
nor faces several charges in the death
of Justine Damon she had called 9-1-1 to
report a possible sexual assault near
her home in July of 2017
NORs says he was startled by Damon dough
on the scene and shot her fearing an
ambush Adriana Diaz is at the Hennepin
County Courthouse in Minneapolis Adriana
good morning good morning John the jury
of 10 men and two women sat through 60
witnesses during the two weeks of
testimony they also saw a graphic body
camera footage showing the attempt to
resuscitate Justine Damon after noir
shot her
prosecutors say Noor acted unreasonably
but his defense says he saw Damon as a
threat now it's up to the jury to decide
former Minneapolis police officer
Muhammad nor said nothing as he left
court Monday afternoon he's charged with
three crimes in the death a 40 year old
Justine diamond second-degree murder
with intent second-degree manslaughter
and third degree murder he took the
stand last week and tried to explain why
he shot her on July 15 2017 daymond
called 9-1-1
Nour said with their squad car lights
off he and his partner drove down an
alley searching for a suspect well the
car was stopped he said they heard a
loud slap on the side of the vehicle and
Damon appeared outside the driver's
window fearing for his partner's life
nor said he fired at Damon from the
passenger seat if you are a police
officer who is involved in a shooting
with deadly force Minnesota law is very
good to you CBS News legal analysts
Ricky Clement says Minnesota law allows
officers to use deadly force if they
perceive a threat the issue of the slap
is the most significant item in this
trial if the juror doesn't believe that
the slap occurred he's getting convicted
during closing arguments NORs defense
attorney slapped his lectern to simulate
the sound that allegedly startled the
officers but prosecutors say that slap
never happened and none of Damon's DNA
was found on the car which was washed
two days after the incident where you
place your attention he's where you
place your energy Daymond
a life coach and yoga teacher was from
Australia she died a month before her
wedding her fiance said at the time he
could hardly imagine going on without
her our lives are forever changed as a
result of knowing her
Damon's fiance and her family have been
in the courtroom during the trial now
the jury is being sequestered until they
reach a verdict
if Nour is convicted of the most serious
charge he could face up to 40 years in
prison Gail is a very difficult case
thank you very much I'd really